- hey welcome everybody to the hippest
coolest jessee's town and show town
[Music]
today's episode is sponsored by
manscaped neon DS pewdiepie was supposed
to be on the show today but due to got
out scheduling issues he was unable to
make it but we rescheduled to February
13th February 12 very well
whoa thank you yeah now today is gonna
be a really one of those episodes
because I'll tell you what keep it going
keep it going
cut out Fredo has this problem where he
makes a diarrhea he licks it all up
right which is just so foul right but
wait till you hear the second part keep
it going don't beat it out where's the
sound bites so he he laughs he laps up
the diarrhea before bed outside and then
at 4:00 a.m. he starts puking diarrhea
and so first there was a big huge puke
at the foot of our bed and I was just
gonna okay you guys you can say that no
it's fun right I told you I was just
talking about how Alfredo puked diarrhea
so first he pukes at the edge of the bed
and it's just immediately
it's brownish but you know you know
whatever it's the stench it smells like
[ __ ] so that's been puked out so it's
also vomit yeah yeah it's on it's
unbelievable and so he pukes at the foot
of the bed then he then I I thought that
was it are usually dogs puke twice so he
puked up the foot of the bed I took him
down and he puked on the floor and I
thought that was it but then as I'm
cleaning I'm just repulsed and I'm
cleaning this pile of vomit [ __ ] at the
foot of the bed he walks over to my
corner of the bed
and where the mattress meets that affect
the frame there's like a tiny little gap
you know where you tuck the sheet in and
he starts digging there I'm like Alfredo
what are you doing I've never seemed
glad and he throws up in that corner but
you can imagine it's just the most
treacherous horrible place you can
imagine cleaning and my trash now it's
like it's got the fabric fabric
you know like the it goes here how do
you clean that he also got it on the
fabric at the foot of the bed till it
actually came out okay but I ended up
picking he's kept puking and then went
in the bathroom and he was like under he
was hiding in our closet I picked on the
rug - he must have puked like eight
times and they all smelled like diarrhea
bro but you know when dogs get really
sick they'll like hide so he was he was
hiding under a bench in the closet and
he was panting and I don't know he looks
so bad mm-hmm so I just cleaned this up
because our whole room spent like
diarrhea so I just cleaned this up and I
throw out all the rags and opened the
window and then I was just really
worried about Alfredo so and then I got
to take off the sheets yeah we just
ended up putting a blanket down or um
I hate that it was the worst I mean it
was the worst and well then I was really
worried about afraid of those four a.m.
and then I took Alfredo outside just to
see what was up it was funny I took him
outside and he was like on the verge of
death and shredder was trying to play
with him shredder was running around the
yard full speed at 4:00 a.m. just like
lunging at Alfredo he didn't get it so I
carry Alfredo upstairs and he it was
really sweet he laid down he was
basically against me the whole night but
I was so scared because he was in just
such bad shape that I kept checking to
see if he was breathing so I didn't get
much sleep
I probably fell asleep at like 5 and
then some suckers who were doing
construction on our house came over at 8
I said they're doing construction right
next to our bedroom I says to the the
guy in charge don't just don't let him
come till 9:30 and he goes ok called
nobody's coming and then they come they
comment 8 just do something really minor
wake us up make a ton of noise and then
they leave why'd you do that
why do construction people always have
to start so early
I've always wondered that either I've
always wondered that why do they have to
start at 8 a.m.
do they not value sleep start at 9 an
hour later yeah
start at 10 even I die now or later like
they leave at 3 there's plenty of
sunlight at 3 what's up most for most
people work later than 3 it's not dark
at 3 there's no reason for this it's
outrageous but anyway at like 6 o'clock
err heard Alfredo get up and go drink
water finally which then I knew he was
ok and I was relieved and this morning
we made him some chicken and rice which
is would they say to feed your dog when
he has an upset stomach and he he ate it
he ate it up he loved it so he's okay
your poop but I was worried man he
looked so bad he was like panting hard
and just staring at us with like yeah he
was all panicked he was feeling really
bad poor baby mm-hmm but unfortunately
I'm alpha get rid of him because he
puked on her bed diarrhea so I'm putting
him back up for adoption taking him back
to the pound just the day before
shredder pukes on our bed and we changed
the sheets so thank you guys you know
what I thought as I was cleaning up his
diarrhea puke I was I was thinking maybe
it was Alfredo
nah those fell shudder yeah you can tell
like on their breath who puked oh man is
that why his breath so stinky stink got
this special stink like unique this
shredder that is just so foul and
powerful but it when you smell it it's
like you love it in a weird way because
you've got your cuz you love your dog
like only sweaters my name is shredder I
think of his smell like stink his thing
yeah he needs a shower though you need
the shower
a week ago they got the last hour now
they're gonna get it are tomorrow
they're getting [ __ ] groomed but man
those guys little stink bombs to sleep
in our bed and puke diarrhea where I put
my head in nightmare Thank You Wendy
Williams so that's that so it's gonna be
one of those shows we have a lot of
interesting topics to get to let me just
show you some of our incredible topics
we're going to talk about the Grammys or
should I say the scam ease Kobe Bryant
tragic I'm sure everybody's heard this
absolutely tragic news we are going to
talk about the mic coronavirus that I've
been falling I have like one of the best
write-ups I've ever done on the
coronavirus I have so much incredible
media here to share with you guys you're
obsessed yes I'm very scared about it
and I think people who are not talking
about it and taking it seriously enough
Jay station has as I predicted brought
his girlfriend back from the dead and
did a Ouija board through am i totally
called that we also totally called that
he was just doing that tomorrow his
second channel we have all the answers
on Jays station ninja the mixer deal we
have the details on that and so much
more you guys are so much more it's
gonna be an incredible ride here today
on the HD podcast experienced instance
can I get a sound effect I don't have to
do my own sound effects experience
how do we get reverb on that since
we never figured out anyway during it
for you um then can you figure it out
yeah why why do we never get reversed
you did get reverb and then and I showed
you how to do it and then you didn't
want to have to deal with it and there
was like there was a whole thing the
whole thing on no no you tried to add a
button on the stream deck but we
couldn't make it work to make it happen
and then I said I could set up a little
iPad for you and you could control it
that way and you were like oh this is
too much
yeah it sounds like a pain in the ass
there's got to be easier way down I need
to be able to say experience and thanks
Dan okay so last episode this is
actually great we had a heated debate
here on the show about who was Philip
defranco's chocolate baited youtubers
yeah and I said I think I'm top 5 yeah I
must be top 5 I see my face there all
the time
no and Dan was hating as usual I've seen
I see you you've already got had dancing
babies you've already rewritten history
a little bit right there we were not
debating the top youtubers click baited
we were debating the top faces top faces
Dan it doesn't matter I think I'm still
top 4 well you're about to try and bust
out some receipts and I'm telling you
those receipts are irrelevant let's let
the people a judge they're not your
realm they're irrelevant
that's only counted why are you hating
so much why do you care you say your
piece is that camera not covering me
those can't the lenses are like touching
it's crazy look at that oh [ __ ] you Dan
[ __ ] you Dan hmm dan why do you care
that much that you want to like burst my
bubble like you're always hating on
because I said you were probably in the
top 10 which I still think is no you
even said talk about rewriting history
you started saying I didn't even think
you're in top 10 really yeah because Ian
if you could be so kind if you guys
would turn your attention to the monitor
both you said both we went to the
archives okay go ahead let's let's see
what is this
why I think I must be one of the most
click baited faces on the philip
defranco show I said you take as a
compliment I feel like I I got to be in
top ten right Here I am again
top ten can I have that title I think
five I'm not giving you your top ten why
are you so paranoid then you had to
prepare that clip in secret because
because we were arguing about it
yesterday and I was like you know what
I'm going into the archives final
conversation but you first of all I
haven't first of all even shown I know
we got away so Ian first of all was
hating the whole way through and II like
you were also hating the whole way
through
I always hate yeah yeah I think you're
coming after me I was willing to give my
meal to him let me open the damn thing
because someone actually did the
research wow they got a lot of what they
got like six gold silver award six
Gold's man people actually this girl did
the research she's like I got nothing to
do she said her name is miss Jackrabbit
thank you to her just as Ethan we should
get her on the call to actually settle
this because let me let me read this
just as either request that I went
through Philip defranco's videos and
tallied up the youtubers who appeared in
the most thumbnails I made a few rules
on the list no mainstream celebrities no
politicians just youtubers this would
look different if I included people like
Donald Trump Jennifer Lawrence and none
of us care about them after counting
everything I'm happy to announce that a
Sri Sri did in fact make the top five
here are the statistics PewDiePie number
one at sixty-one videos Logan poll
number two at 44 Shane Dawson at 29
videos is number three and number four
h3h3 at 26 videos fourth place I edged
out even Jake Paul in fifth place at 24
videos
but it I don't think first of all she
doesn't ever claim that Jennifer Laurent
why would Jennifer Lawrence being so
many thumbnail it makes sense what is
she doing but so newsworthy don't Donald
Trump I can see him being in fifth yeah
maybe
Jennifer Lawrence how many times she
being a thumbnail five yeah I thought
that was weird too but maybe I mean was
a lot of drama or a few years ago that
uh the fat been happening okay but how
many times you can put her in a
thumbnail for Christ no I don't think it
was just the last year I think this was
the totality of there's no way that
Jennifer Lawrence has more clickbait
yeah I'm probably not thanked but I
don't know but I don't know we don't
you'll have the day popa clip we don't
have the day okay fine but I'm in the
top five why are you trying to take that
away from me youtubers that wasn't the
debate well then we need to get the
evidence because dan is just being a
little punk-ass I think that you'll be
in the top ten overall I'm willing to
give you that I feel like I feel like
she understood the intention of well yo
Yori go ahead yo speak I was proven
wrong and I'm impressed
thank you you even you even passed Jake
Paul and I was just behind Shane Dawson
if I'm being honest I mean I remember I
was making videos Jake Paul was like the
dad clickbait natan you know true Logan
Paul's held on to the title pretty
strongly though that's true and
PewDiePie is far and away number one but
nobody surprised by that but look at me
how I feel so validated I feel so like
relevant like I I do feel like my ego
has been stroked a little bit but we
haven't made videos and so long we just
sit here doing this dumb podcast and yet
here I am Here I am the boss talked
about figure probably because I just say
dumb [ __ ] all the time get in trouble
you know it's just I'm in his show every
time I say some stupid [ __ ] and I try to
get so much as answer me some of them
because we we call it you know
clickbait a lot of it isn't click really
click baby
it is a story about the first minute but
a lot of them with you genuinely is
clickbait because the only appearance
that you have in his whole video will be
like and Ethan said this about this
other story and thank you for pointing
that out because I did notice a lot of
people saying well it's not clickbait I
don't know why they're saying that and
well I agree and I'm not even using it
in a negative term because clickbait
like [ __ ] mad yes on are all the time
I do that all the time would be like
Trisha Paytas five minutes in the title
that's just the nature of the game yeah
you want to get those views baby you
going I'll grade them and they think
they're fighting click away they are
create and click me you know I don't
know what they're doing but yeah there
you kind of have to click bait right now
so true well I think in their mind I
don't know what clickbait is in their
mind I didn't know anything I don't know
but to me I just find it funny and
flattering frankly to that he thinks my
name can pull views I think that's a but
I think that's really flattering he goes
like Dan said you know it's like
anything uh look at this Nathan said
that Trish's
a cow next story and then and that he
puts me in the thumbnail toilet yes Dan
you see that filly replied in that row
yeah yes let's find out he actually had
a great question thanks Dan I can hate
this new reddit I don't he was awful I
only use old reddit Philip DeFranco he
said this is impressive can you do the
math and see who pulls in the best views
of her average plus highs and lows
actually I am quite curious about that
too but Philly's actually just wants the
data so he can improve his clickbait
good but I'm glad that he acknowledged
the hard work that this person put in in
fact you guys should see ya what the
hell we got to get a hold of this garage
check and she actually went through the
effort of downloading this I am she
downloaded every thumbnail and then
break break them by tears should do this
for free so
yeah I mean no she just with her free
time reach up to her damn we got to put
her on payroll okay we've got beauty pie
Logan Shayne hdhd yeah like every
episode fact check everything Ethan said
that oh god what a nightmare
no thank you so here let's try to guess
what what we're talking about YouTube is
broken I don't know Ethan I don't know I
don't know I don't know be kpop I don't
know I don't know okay so this game's
not that fun it turns out you gotta
admit though even ninjas down here then
just got less clickbait power than your
bar maybe he's just less in the news
because my dumb ass is only same dumb
[ __ ] savings over X below me Liza oh
she's below me all right go ahead
Guardiola take it and leafy so
understand
I guess my title doesn't mean that much
hopefully if he's still on this list to
do doesn't made a video in like three
years I think it's time it's only in the
last year no I think Dan was saying this
is over the hole no no this isn't the
last year wait this is all time yes
that's what I was trying to say this is
like that's why I mean sixty one videos
for PewDiePie that would be insane if it
wasn't sixty one and oh so maybe I
shouldn't be that flattered cuz I I
guess maybe I used to be more relevant
now nobody cares about me I want to know
the last year that's what I'm interested
in even in the last year you were in a
decent amount but but not in the time
okay okay so it's all invalid we need we
need her to put her we need to put her
on payroll and get her yeah and get her
doing more tearless okay okay even I
don't [ __ ] in the morning for the
Parkers it's the worst uh I always try
to like chug coffee and squeeze it out
before I leave because I know this will
happen it's so annoying I don't want to
lecture you right now but you gotta give
yourself more time to get ready
well I
a little I don't know if you listen to
the beginning of this there okay so I
got a show to run we got nine minutes
till brick can you hold it
I can all work for nine minutes can you
squeeze it out at the time of the break
because no more important I'd like 20
minutes that's the problem
Papa John posted this on his stories
well I'll try to hold it but if I need
to then we're just gonna have to I can't
make a car okay
asking for cowboy boots advice
those look like um snakeskin those only
good papa tweeted her shared this on
Instagram should I wear these when I go
on a stress free podcast in a couple
weeks of 93 97% it actually went up to
98% yes because I restored it basic to
legend I love I'm like Papa's like my
best friend right now is your papa he's
my actual my father figure he's my real
dad I'm asking Phil adopt me week from
Friday I just proved that Wendy ripped
ass at least I can talk about it and
like acknowledge what's going on but
wendy is trying to be like it's my
backbone get your backbone okay it's
stinking in there right you smell it no
oh man you guys got to see this this
Dannan in somebody noticed something
really interesting submitted it dan and
Ian turned their heads at the same exact
time on the podcast yeah I mean I guess
yeah it's pretty
[Laughter]
[Music]
is that these are cyborgs or lizard
people or some [ __ ] people always say
that they think that we're brothers well
I know that's not true
we're also not cyber I would say cyborgs
above brothers well brothers implies you
guys are human a lot of people think
we're the same person - yeah don't know
we're different I'm not sure how to
support that theory
you got greeted as Dan yeah I was at the
movies and the guy came up where are you
dairy podcast how do i casually watch
they're not mega fans I think I'm I'm
gonna hold it in but I think I gotta
take a [ __ ] on the break ok it's alright
I haven't used to wiping so long so
it'll be interesting are you gonna make
me rhymes you're gonna have to make it
in time during the break I'm not gonna
make it in time they're gonna have a car
I can't you think I get [ __ ] in five
minutes I could try I'll try I'll try it
but I feel like I need to let my [ __ ]
breathe well you know you told me I'm
just explaining to you you asked me if I
could make it in five minutes
I don't think you can make in five
minutes are you we're gonna have to do a
cut second we're gonna have to do a cut
do roll to the break we'll be back right
now
breaking news this important PSA is
brought to you by manscaped comm this is
your pubic service announcement the
manscaped engineering team has spent 18
months perfecting the greatest ball hair
trimmer ever created and just released
the new and improved lawn mower 3.0
ILA's super excited because she knows I
got my hands on this thing and God Lord
knows I need it
they're third-generation trimmer
features a cutting edge ceramic blade to
prevent manscaping accidents millions of
balls are about to be knit free thanks
to manscaped advanced skin safe
technology now the balls are one problem
but the shaft is actually where I always
Nick myself do you guys find the shaft
to be a issuer's it's as follows it's
all dangerous yeah it's all bad I've
done it so many times and I have to tell
you I you don't believe that it's
possible you just get you get like PTSD
it's so difficult to manscape but yeah I
know yeah it's horrific and but when you
get a hold of this manscaped you're
gonna understand what it feels like to
clean and mow your pubic regions free of
anxiety and fear and to come out looking
fresh and and and beautiful like a
freshly mowed lawn as they as they have
said if you've ever used their lawn
mower 2.0 it's an easy transition
because the same replacement is the same
replacement blade with a new improved
skin-safe technology when I tell you
this is premium I mean Premium I would
put nothing less to my balls in shaft
the battery will last up to 90 minutes
and I need all 90 minutes of them to
shave when the coolest features is the
LED light which illuminates grooming
areas for a closer and more precise
trimming my genitals are a black hole I
need all the light I can get they've
also upgraded to a 7000 rpm motor with
quiet stroke technology that's what I do
when heel is sleeping when I need to
take care of myself quite stroke
technology let's not forget about the
charging stand show your mower off loud
and proud because this intelligently
designed right that's why I put mine at
the
entrance of the house where I could
proudly show everyone that I use it and
tells you intelligently designed Stan is
a rapid charging dock powered by USB if
you are listening to me speak right now
you are one of the first people to hear
about this life-changing product and I
want you to experience first hand for
yourself trim that junk of yours get 20%
off plus free shipping with the code
h3h3 at man escapes calm and as always
your balls will thank you 20% off free
shipping with code h3h3 at manscape comm
that's 20% off with free shipping and
manscaped comm use code h3h3
love is in the air someone grab the
Lysol just kidding even even though this
is a made-up holiday it's still cute
it's also the perfect time to show that
special someone how much you care and
say those three words everybody wants to
hear sniff my balls I mean match my
undies me undies has the most adorable
Valentine's Day prints to get all
lovey-dovey this year don't worry you
don't have a boob
mandis also makes buddy bands so you can
match with your pets which is honestly
more important to people that's so
depressing I love me undies it's soft
it's incredible it's unbelievable it I'm
voluptuous young man and I neat and I
have curves and needs that most men
don't so if your voluptuous like me this
is gonna hug your Vil UPS if you're
slender like ela then it's just gonna
it's gonna you're gonna be embraced
exactly you give me embrace by micro
modal which is three times softer than
cotton it's outrageous
trust me mm en DS is the real deal happy
Valentine's Day everyone to show how
much they love you me Andes has not one
but three new Valentine's Day prints
this year this is the perfect
opportunity to show that special someone
you're ready to take to the next level
with a matching bear match me so I know
it's real is the Moto this year if
you're matching your BFF or even your
dog it still counts also someone told us
that Mandy's has new loungewear rumor
has its it's loungewear that you can
wear out and about keep your eyes peeled
on some cozy new additions here we go we
got an offer for you guys Mandy's has a
great offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchaser you get 15% off and
free shipping it's a no-brainer
especially because they offer a 100%
satisfaction guarantee that means if you
don't like it you send your dirty on
these back to them so please sniff some
and then they throw them out that's 50%
of your first pair free shipping and
100% satisfaction guarantee go to me on
DS comm slash h3 that's me on DS comm
slash h32
we're back that what just happened was
my worst nightmare come I wonder if I
ate something that afraid it it cuz I
just had like an explosive unrefined you
know when your poop is like totally
unrefined it's just a mound of waste
it's just a mound of waste mm-hmm like
what did I eat yesterday that could have
cuz I didn't even eat out what today
just a mound of waste at home I wish I
had the bad day so badly but like yeah I
do what it mm-hmm well at any rate I was
in there I didn't have time to put down
the paper on the toilet seat
what no I was like I was like what Red
Alert when I got in there
no I'm telling you I didn't have time
that there is no such thing you don't do
that
it looked like someone had just cleaned
it so I was like [ __ ] it I'm going for
it I didn't have time you're not hearing
no you're not understanding me I am
understanding you are not understanding
what do you want to divorce me cuz I
take a desperate [ __ ] is your phone
vibrating you uh after all the [ __ ] you
gave me vibrate can every kind of people
please slam on either right now well I
don't understand this phone it's what's
his phone just put it on the table so it
doesn't shake the whole room there what
the [ __ ] I was talking about something
important I didn't have time to clean I
mean I sat I didn't clean I didn't put
before anything do you understand that I
was thinking about that corn being
getting quarantined sounds kind of dumb
like if I get caught or if like everyone
starts getting coronavirus yeah I go
from here straight to the shower
you don't want to eat my ass sometimes I
don't want you to even touch anything I
can't believe you just set on the toilet
I had no choice not an option for me I
would like I would like you don't
understand where I was I would [ __ ]
standing and I would not say you
wouldn't [ __ ] stand I would do anything
in my power before I sit on an uncovered
sit in a disgusting public ELA you're
not hearing me I why are you judging and
I didn't have an option
did you see how sick of Fredo was last
night that's I felt like we ate the same
thing what the [ __ ] did we eat you think
I want to sit on a public uncovered like
I I would faint first before I do that
okay well I didn't want to [ __ ] my pants
on the floor of the bathroom yeah it's
easy for you to sit there and uh you
know talk about what if but when been
there but when what when you're faced
with a crisis you have to make decisions
yeah I've been there
this was the Cuban Missile Crisis I had
to decide the Cuban colon crisis I'm
just really horrified I've never had to
do that is this a deal I don't know what
you want from me I have you I'm not
happy about it you know I'm not happy
about the whole thing I was in there it
was like a mound of [ __ ] and I was
wiping with the baby wipes in the bottom
of the baby horse we're getting dipped
in [ __ ] you can see the bottom of the
baby was [ __ ] disgusting hundred
percent yes because the mound is so high
but you know what I did learning things
you know what I did I took I don't I
hate the one thing I can't tolerate is
the water splashing on my ass yeah the
water in the toilet I don't want on me
that's
for sure so I took like what I took like
probably a hundred because I was in so
hurry I usually just take three to put
it on the water so then splash I took
like a hunch turret of the seat covers
and I just threw it in there what could
I do
I flushed it all down they're not
clogged no I thought I had to flush
three times so I'm in there and then
some old dude comes in and sits next to
me you just clogged like the whole LA
City no those are those are very um
those things are so thin they
disintegrate and well that's baby wipes
the baby wipes those no I use too many
though many objects that people touch
every day are dirtier than a toilet seat
said Dan mythbuster Dan I just like
because I remembered you remember the
show MythBusters right of course yeah
well they I remembered an episode where
they tested how like how many germs are
on a toilet seat and it was less than a
kitchen sponge money light switches
phone computer keyboard Hotel remote
shopping cart cell phone yeah and the
toilet seat had the least amount of
germs that are either you know what it's
occurred to me and I've actually cuz I
used to be paranoid to get like a STD
from it but you can't catch it's it's
not that bad the toilet seat I think
it's just like if phobia that I have I
it's not my preference bro usually I'll
meticulously cover it and they'll be
like little holes and I'll get like a
squirt all the paper and fill in every
oh like a plague Tetris on the toilet
seat but anyway yeah I'm in there and
I'm wrapping it up it's smells bro it's
like sweet sick death like you know
sometimes I imagine this what a dead
body smells like cuz it's like it's like
putrid but with a tinge of like sweet
I've heard it described that's what a
dead body's in this story
some people know what I'm talking about
yeah someone's like that I've heard
corpse described as sweet smelling
cuz it's like there's like I don't know
there's like a edge to the decaying it's
like a sharp not sweet but like it's the
only way I can describe it it's like
it's a heightened stink
it's like it's heightened I know what
you're talking about
dead bodies give off a distinctive
sickly sweet odor they're immediately
recognizable hard to forget huh it's
almost like a like a slight peppermint
weird thank you
see so it smells like a dead body I
think my shits this one in particular
anyway a guy walked in i immediately
felt so bad because i could barely stand
it and then i
he finished before me and i was done
basically the same time and i was just
standing in the stall and sharing
writing from dillio those so embarrassed
to come out at the same time I feel like
that's normal go you would you guys ever
would you guys wait or would you just oh
yeah I definitely wait yeah no is that
interesting you don't want it to see you
don't want them to see your face I was
even hiding my feet I walked to the edge
of the stall they wouldn't even see my
feet I survived thankfully no I won't
keep it I want you to eat my ass tonight
our culture I'm wearing pants you know
you're wearing shorts right yeah you
think that it's all my like thighs or
something
come on we got mean we have a lot to get
to maybe I'll save the memes cuz we're
going out of extraordinarily slow pace
the Grammys I don't care about that much
should I talk about whatever I mean what
am I gonna do here I don't really care
about the ground missile guys tell you I
mean no war shows are so stupid why are
there so many I know it's like it
doesn't stop how many what do we just
have the Emmys the Academy Award the
Grammys the Tony's I mean they're all
for different things but it's all the
same people but it's all the same people
dead babies aren't
I don't know I see the same I see the
same people at every award show why is
the same people at every award show if
it's different things I'm not there's
different ways for musicians right yeah
is for music but there's more than a
most Tony's for for theater okay but the
same [ __ ] people there and then you
have the Academy Awards the same people
go there you're probably thinking like
the Golden Globe there are too many
movie war or too many movies
you can't yeah
anyway I agree that the Grammys suck so
I'm not gonna argue with you on that
Billy Eilish won every award she won the
big four apparently whatever that is
song record album of the Year and Best
New Artist so congratulations to Billy
I'm happy wish you know she deserves it
you know but she wanted apparently she
wanted ariana grande to win is that
right in you're a fan of Ariana's what
did they want her to win the best album
or something
I I guess I'll mother year I'm not sure
I think so though so her fans were upset
and they set the hashtag scam 'is going
in honor of in honor of their girl
Ariana
Ian's downplaying how upset he was he
about the scam ease that night no for
different reasons
hmm why did you okay you use the term
scam 'is not going to work why are you
withholding your thoughts why ours dang
getting and but like I don't know
anything about ariana grande like I just
yeah in I'm serious you have to step it
up here you have to talk you this is
your [ __ ] you used to always hear from
you people love hearing from you and now
you're like Bing Dan now you just think
you don't even want to be here what the
[ __ ]
touching this one man no ya don't mean
to sell you out like this about scam I
didn't watch I don't want
I know because I asked I I messaged Dan
you're right I messaged him saying oh
did you see
Tyler's performance or whatever he's
like I am watching the scam ease go
ahead he and what do you mean by that I
said that as a joke just a goof on the
people that are freaking out eyes I
didn't watch
I actually I know you heard her album
about that I don't care about the
Grammys I haven't watched in like five
years
I think they're terrible and out of
touch I hate the Grammys okay but
Ariana's nominated or not I don't give a
[ __ ] cuz I don't care about that
organization so are you downplaying
Billy as sweep of the big four
categories I don't care about any of the
sweeps I just don't like the Grammys I
think that they're usually wrong and
they're all decent vote between Billy
and Ariana
who's winning best new album best album
of the year
I mean I like - Ariana's more but
probably more than impact in the
industry so I'd probably give it to her
I suppose
are you guys familiar with Christopher
Cross do you know who that artist is now
for cross
no you know who he is he he's the last
person that won the big four just like
Billy Isla yeah good point and I don't
think Billy what wait who is that I
think that's what I said was that from
from like the late 70s or something yes
I do is he still active Oh what the hell
look at this good is big but it's also I
don't know I mean I don't want to take
anything away from the legend bro how
did I not hear about him looks like
today looks like Kyle Gass what is he
looking right he looks like a rock and
roller
it's like Yacht rock oh that's not awful
like Jimmy Buffett or like wow there was
a time when Jimmy Buffett was winning
Rock yeah you never heard that term
before it's like soft soft rock soft
rock it's like it's for yuppies for
white when they hit for white out on
their yachts
I love Yacht rock what are you talking
Zach to be fair I haven't necessarily
found anything you dislike okay that's
true cream cheese well I do think
Billy's talented and I don't think she
will go the way of Yacht rock let me
know it's different gross Christopher
Cross it is a thing that the Best New
Artist Award in particular is known to
be cursed because most of the winners of
it go on to be one-hit wonder right
people I don't think that's gonna happen
to her no way beyond that but but most
people that win it do kind of get
screwed well there was one interesting
take here Tyler the Creator who has been
traditionally snubbed by mainstream
media and awards won he won Best Rap
Album of the year but he was not
nominated for album of the Year category
so he took he took he took kind of a as
a backhanded compliment and here's what
he said about it which is kind of an
interesting take today I'm half in half
on it on one side I'm very grateful that
what I made could just be you know
acknowledged in a world like this but
also it sucks that whenever we and I
mean guys that look like me do anything
that genre-bending or that's anything
they always put it in a rap or urban
Khaled category which is and I don't
like that urban word is just a
politically correct way to say the inner
word to me so when I hear that I'm just
like why can't we just be in pop like a
ninja you know what I mean so I felt
like a half of me feels like the the rap
nomination was a backhanded compliment
like oh my little cousin wants to play
the game let's give him the unplugged
controllers so he could
shut up and feel good about it that
that's what it felt like a bit but
another half of me is very grateful that
the art that I mean could be
acknowledged on a level like this when I
don't do the radio stuff I'm not played
in target I'm in a whole different world
than what a lot of people here listening
to so I'm grateful and like so what are
your thoughts on that yeah yeah I agree
yeah I think he's right
I think the Grammys are always wrong
about this time you think do you think
that you know I I'm actually a big fan
of Tyler's I would listen to flower boy
a lot but I haven't listened to Igor
that much just because I that's where he
like changed his voice right he like
pitch shifted down yeah he does a lot of
times yeah I'm not I'm not a big fan of
that I just I never been a fan of that
style I want to hear his voice you know
but so I didn't listen to it that much
but would you consider Igor a rap album
I wouldn't know
definitely not I it's just weird like
how do you define where would you put a
post Milan then yeah I agree
right although he was was he nominated
post more was he nominated for rap or
for that's not how many nominations for
sunflower just that song yeah right okay
it might have been like written one of
the generic categories like record of
the year was there a category for like
rock and roll or why don't other is yeah
there is so or if you look at like like
God's plan by Drake one like best rap
song last year that's like not a rap
song I don't know it's pop that is
really wack yeah and he's especially
right about that urban thing like that
just seems like everything's black yeah
in the way that they use it just feels
weird best urban album it's like that's
never been a genre that anybody refers
to like I listen to urban music like
what it sounds racist yes said that I
like herb imagine a white guy I like
urban music what does that mean
yeah I think he's got a really good
point mm-hmm well so but apparently no
yeah I'm glad he got acknowledged
because I know that he always wanted to
be acknowledged and played on the radio
and such because he never was so it's
cool that he was acknowledged but I I
hear he's coming from you know do you
see that he retweeted a tweet that he
had saved from like 2012 of some dude
talking [ __ ] to him on Twitter about how
he'll never win a Grammy you know he had
it ready to go
I actually it's so good I find it I'll
pull it up yeah thank you
I did see that I want to show it though
I wonder
I guess what the Grahams are saying is
that they didn't think it was album of
the year are there ever any hip-hop
albums in album of the year
nominated they're very rarely I think
only to have everyone Outkast and then
Lauryn Hill in the 90s I think they only
to ever know Kent liked to pimp a
butterfly never know kendrick first well
that was the first one where I kind of
started checking out where he lost to
Macklemore for best rap album what yes
and then he lost again to pimp a
butterfly lost to Taylor Swift and ha
that's where I stopped watching oh my
god I different followed this all this
[ __ ] but I think everybody agrees that
to pimp a butterfly is like album of the
decade it yeah I did on what they win
did he win wrap-up of the year with
butterfly I think he did yeah I think
you did but that to pimp a butterfly was
reading also influenced David Bowie's
last record before he died oh yeah
that's pretty cool
forget Rick wow that Macklemore beep to
pimp a butterfly it
that's not he'd be a good kid maad see
yeah well that's another classic yeah
that to me I can't even compute that so
I guess I know you're coming from now
again it seems crazy cuz it feels like
um this stuff should be way past where
we are today but
I it's not like the what he said I think
is really true interest right I think on
Saturday night P Diddy did a speech at
one of these Grammies events saying like
this [ __ ] has been going on way too long
I'm giving you guys one year and then
the people in this room can definitely
change the course of this it was like
jay-z was there and Beyonce was there
and stuff so I think it could be cool if
after a year if he feels like change
hasn't really happened they could go and
make like a new award show I think I
think P Diddy and jay-z and people like
that could definitely pull something
like that off so I think if yeah I think
they should just stop giving awards to
Taylor Swift and [ __ ] Oh big I I'm
processing what you said I can't believe
it Taylor Tyler said I favorited this
nine years ago just for the moment to
tell you I got one yes I'm petty as [ __ ]
good day Mark Martin said don't be too
excited you won't get one in 2011 in
response to I don't even know why it's
so old oh because what he changed his
Twitter handle it said at [ __ ] Tyler oh
maybe that's why the original and now it
says Tyler the Creator nice good for you
that's real street cred when you can
change your Twitter handles good for
Tyler though I'm a fan and I'm happy for
him that guy that guy's a talent I mean
he's such a talent he's a treasure he's
an American treasure so good for him and
good that he had a moment of speaking
out what Zach did you guys listen to his
odd future stuff I really I really
honestly just really I've been following
him I like the singles but the first oh
my god to was flower boy which is still
one which we listen to a lot I really
like a great record yeah
alrighty well very cool if
did post Malone when anything at the
Grammys in previous years who knows but
maybe I think he did actually hmm
Kobe Bryant Bryant as everybody knows
has a suffered a tragic helicopter crash
actually in our neck of the woods and so
it was so weird that like I don't know
if people outside LA I know he's like
world famous but in LA where I grew up
and still live to this day Kobe Bryant
was like he was like a god here he
played for the Lakers for 20 years the
best years the Lakers ever had him in
Shaq they were just winning
championships it was like this such an
exciting time to be in LA everybody's
watching the Lakers but Kobe you know
it's so rare that the player plays in a
city his whole career 20 years he played
in LA he was a Laker all the way so for
me and and everybody here in LA they're
used to seeing his name seeing him on
the TV
my dad's a hardcore Laker fan so he was
always he was always on our TV at home
at 41 years old but actually what's
crazy is that when the news broke I was
hearing that his family wasn't on there
but then when you can ask 13 old
daughter was on there with them [ __ ] I
can't imagine losing your child in that
way so you know everybody's talking
about Kobe Bryant so I will instead of
eulogizing him and the normal fashion
you guys probably all seen I prepared
some clips that we can watch actually in
Memorial Kobe Bryant insane shots
let's check it out oh yeah people were
the night that the newt or the morning
the news broke people went out to
Staples Center which is where the Lakers
play and they were just having a
memorial service for him which is it was
so weird cuz the Grammys happened at the
Staples Center the same night so it was
a strange just strange vibe down there
[Applause]
I'm just gonna say this one club because
I'm afraid this will just go on for too
long here with the best insane shots but
this is one of the most epic Kobe Bryant
moments in NBA history he was having
this long drawn-out beef with his player
Matt Barnes okay and it was getting
really dirty between them
lots of shoulders and elbows was getting
you see them these are the two guys they
were like that's the whole game just
bumping chest he was getting in his head
this guy Matt Barnes and Kobe was known
for his head game cuz he was so cool he
was like the best player one of like top
three players ever just so dominant and
he was getting in this head he was known
for never losing his cool and getting in
his head and there was this moment where
he kind of came to a boiling point and
this guy it has damn it feels good to be
a gangster playing so you know but I'm
not gonna play the music obviously
because I but so he has a foul he gets
the ball and he fakes it right at Kobe's
face and Kobe doesn't flinch at all and
people kept talking about like how could
you not flinch how could you not even
flinch it was awesome anyway beyond
being a bat a great basketball player he
was a role model to a lot of kids like
excuse me I'm gonna say this guy's and
uh it's going to say urban kids mm-hmm
he ain't give me a call on that
what give me a verdict can I say urban
kids we just decided you can Oh in the
last segment we didn't say you cut it we
said it was it was racist I think a lot
of people we didn't decide that dan how
dare you a lot of people looked up to
Kobe as a role model the guy was the
king of LA he was a good guy he was
always supporting charities and a good
dad it's just crazy man you know so
foggy that day people we don't really
know what happened yet but people were
just saying it was so foggy you could
barely see it was like milk there when
they crashed but it's kind of it's just
so ironic I like if he wasn't so rich
that he could afford a helicopter it's
like you get so rich and you start doing
all this [ __ ] like flying in your
private plane and helicopters and
theoretically it's not supposed to crash
but he's kind of funny that like in a
parallel universe where he's not as
successful he survives
Wow that just I don't know that could
happen any other way you think car
accident you think the UH I just I don't
like even thinking about that stuff it's
like yeah that was his life he was you
had to travel a lot and he was using
what so he was famous for flying his
helicopter everywhere and he said that
he was to be able to practice as much as
he needed to to be good at basketball
and to still have time for his family he
started flying helicopters yeah I mean
it would turn it's it's kind of crazy
how convenient it was it would turn a
drive from Calabasas downtown LA which
would probably take an hour it's like a
five-minute helicopter ride well who
knows what happened but yeah that that
news shocked shocked the city for sure
we were trying to find Kobe jerseys it's
like sold out everywhere I was cruising
around the street I saw people like with
drinks in their hand and a Kobe
uniform no it's pretty wild
his daughter though I just the whole
story is so sad and even beyond them
that there's another family that was
like mom died and a kid it was his
daughter's coach and his family but this
said that stories is tragic as [ __ ] yeah
it's the coach his wife and his daughter
yeah the whole family got wiped out and
they probably don't know if they have
kids that survived them but can you
imagine I just can't imagine like oh so
tragic to be with I mean I only know
because I have a son now but to be in
that situation where to lose both of
them from the wife's perspective and the
other sisters unimaginable and also he
was just about to retire he had retired
or just retired he recently retired but
basketball players have like really long
careers after retirement and he I think
he had a lot of a lot left to give you
know at that young age of 41 yes crazy
but the truth is that as you said you
know damn it's like he was in perfect
shape he had the perfect life he had it
all but he still died and his daughter
his porn that's the support that [ __ ]
me up and I wish his daughter wasn't on
there and all their videos together
they're so cute he's so sweet and great
dad yeah she was a basketball player and
you she used to go to all the basketball
games with him that's where they were
traveling together I read a story that
him and his wife had a pact that they
would never fly on the helicopter
together yeah interesting turned out to
be recall is that like that just seems
like they knew it was dangerous well my
brother's because my brother flew in
helicopters and he said that it's the
most dangerous it's just a death trap
there was no way when something goes
wrong there's no way to it's like a
you just follow the air like it doesn't
fly like a airplane like an airplane if
the engine dies you can glide yeah the
helicopter is just like a bag of dirt
falling to the earth but it sounds to me
from what I have heard this morning as
they get more details is that it was so
foggy that the pilot didn't realize he
was as low as he was and they just
crashed into the side of a hill over the
calabasas hills they were flying to
Thousand Oaks for a basketball game for
his daughter where do you land a
helicopter in Thousand Oaks in the
parking lot I'm sure is hot didn't we
see a video where the CEO of like
Budweiser took his helicopter all drunk
and parked it remember that yeah yeah he
went he was he was drunk helicopter
driving okay I can't imagine it's easy
to just Park a helicopter but well
that's neither that's not really the
subject of the debate right ela but
anyway the Kobe story
rest in peace is not without its gaffes
a reporter on air talking about his
death said what seems to sound like the
n-word and YouTube YouTube censors
before you do monetize my own video and
banned me from YouTube for playing this
she didn't say the n-word okay but judge
for yourself so what she apparently said
is that she mixed up the word vixen and
Lakers and said nickers nickers so I'm
emphasizing the K there the nickers but
so I listen to it like a hundred times
because at first I was like she said the
n-word there's no way but I the more I
listen the more I hear the K yeah oh you
have to well
and a star that was perfectly cast on
the Los Angeles [ __ ] no it sounds
like it's the best goof ever I mean are
you
I believe her explanation of like why
she flubbed it but I don't hear okay
listen carefully listen I feel like it's
just hard to say but I I was hearing it
last night but now I don't hear it I
can't hear nickers she go there she
doesn't pronunciate the K part so much
it's just the nickers C gonna clip me
saying that now like no I said knickers
the knickers can you imagine what in her
head is going in the video
oh I thought he said something
can you sound by isolate the knickers
zackham can we pull it just listen to it
a few times you know and then I think
that's the best way because you can
start to really feel what she's saying
what is this I added this be Brian's
daughter as Gianna was traveling with
him oh yeah the BBC was running a
memorial story on Kobe and they showed a
picture of LeBron caught Ryan's daughter
so I was traveling with him and also
died that's were bribed his list of
achievements is you're an all-star an
NBA champion and a little bit gold
medalist he was unashamedly competitive
they're still showing LeBron James on a
Jersey it was cut short by you Jason
that's LeBron James the whole time
Bryan's do you think like
a big official company does something
things like that won't happen
Wow whoops they're British they they
don't pay attention to basketball if
they do well if you're doing a tribute
to someone who died you better at least
hit their face all around the world of
course of course [ __ ] you Dan
you got that knickers
soundbite for me he's pulling it right
now yeah okay I think this is one of the
saddest stories you know you don't
expect a celebrity death to like it's
like you hate you like you always
thought like oh well you know who cares
I didn't know him but it just was so
unexpected and he was so young I guess
it's also and then the daughter here in
LA it feels so close yeah it feels like
personal like someone family member I
think in LA I know in LA it hit really
hard yeah I mean I grew up here too and
I'm not really a basketball fan but it
it's hard to overstate just how like
ubiquitous Kobe was like just my entire
life basically and when he start playing
in like the mid 90s or something so I
was like a little kid so pretty much
from like elementary school on he's just
always been present you know what I mean
and so it's just surreal but he's just
gone in an instant like that it's
important to the city and like I said
he's played his whole career here in LA
right well so it's like such an awful
way to go I can only imagine you know it
probably was really well I'm hoping that
it was sudden and quick if they crashed
into the side of a mountain it kind of
could have been that they didn't even
know what hit what what happened yeah if
that's what happened and he just seems
like such a nice guy yeah he was a class
act for sure total class act and
obviously everyone on the board I mean
we're all just focusing on him but
there's nine people there yeah the other
family got wiped off the face of the
planet it's not crazy
uh Zack
ya think he's got it just now he's
acting Zack Zack Zack Zack Zack Zack I'm
ready to move on to the coronavirus so
I'm waiting on you mieka Rona keep going
I feel like I can't hear it keep going I
tell ya I'm hearing the N word I heard
the cake I'm starting I wasn't hearing
the cake at all when he's spamming it
like they're gonna hear it a little bit
I thought that this would this would a
little bit I thought this would help her
but I'm not hearing it anymore
go ahead take out the cut at the end cuz
she tries to correct so I just want the
clean take out the cut yeah knickers
Neela's cleaner well there's no in no
world even if she was like a mega racist
Andrey actuallity would she ever no do
that argument is a it's more about what
was the the sub-conscience
exactly but consciously that explanation
makes sense
but I think she was really just
innocently what she said I think that's
true yeah
it's gotta be one of the best news flubs
ever better than negative it's probably
so so good like out of context I don't
think we can play it cuz people would
just think we're running the N word
because we like to run these you know on
sound bites
go ahead just let me hear it this is the
last time we'll ever be able to hear
this so let me just take it in nickers
nickers I don't know okay I'm gonna be
like the blue and gold dress but with
the worst word you
can imagine okay Thank You Zack well you
guys judge for yourself I think he was
right I I pardon her we're clearing her
yeah she's pardon okay go ahead with the
UH with the sting guys we're moving on
to our next topic
the corona virus which is obsessed with
I am the guys put this together at last
minute last night we got a my Corona
parody song and a dude sipping a Corona
mixed with Chinese people dying
go ahead one more time I gotta joy that
again here's the virus and that is AK
thing yeah that was Zack Zack the [ __ ]
the magician musician thank you through
that together where can people will
listen to your music Zack I'm just on
Instagram yeah what is it Z underscore
vinyl Z underscore vine and change it to
sound like I can probably get you didn't
I know someone Instagram that can change
your handle that'd be cool Zack sound
lad Zack this online what about Zack the
mayo eating sound laughs I know a
Scottish fan emailed me and pointed out
that sound lad is slang in Scotland for
like a good guy like a good dude oh it
sounds loud oh I like that he's a sound
laughs thank you that's cool
Ian did the Edit by the way too I want
to give all credit I and you can follow
Ian on instagram at the plugs and the
credits for this well dance well Dan
didn't do anything but I'll give credit
Dan he produces the show dance word love
and I got a handle on screen right now
oh my god you guys are getting lots of
followers I noticed you guys all have
like 10
thousand followers now right you know
what it primarily was was the day that
we went to Disneyland Oh put us all in
all your stories over and over yeah
that's awesome though it's probably fun
to have some followers I guess yeah
you've got fans come on it's awesome Dan
go what do you go private if you don't
care no I I guess I appreciate it yeah I
shouldn't say that I don't care Ian's
trying to get verified for real for
what's trying to give back because I got
on the train I can get you guys verified
you guys want verified I'll take it
verification if you quit ever though if
you ever walk bozo
I'll make sure it gets removed and I'll
change your handle back I think we need
at least one power point for the check
mark the verified thing is I kind of the
check marks it it seems like a scam
because he and said he applied a couple
times and got rejected I see people with
like way less followers in him with
check marks all the time what's up yeah
probably because they have connections
to larger larger organizations because
really like my guy on Instagram probably
can get all you guys verified so it's
just a matter of knowing someone
couldn't okay good yeah I have a task
for each of you mmm-hmm yes to earn
their check mark yeah no but then we
already gave him one for next week which
I'm very excited about yeah I'm excited
about that for sure Ian we are
desperately in need of a PowerPoint mmm
desperate do we give them a topic or two
let him decide you can't decide that's
always happened to organic it's just not
a lot of interesting stuff but I figured
two P key B is very picky I agree
sometimes you know necessity is the
mother of creation in we just want
something you cannot wait all the time
for perfect inspiration to be a creative
artist you should know that hint you
should know that by now okay and what's
always acts assignment it's to make a
little segment of us all talking and
it's also known by its
okay so wait wait you want a segment
where nobody's talking can I talk well
you I should be able to stop to be part
of the plan I should be able to talk
well I think no the idea was to just
make one we're in I can have a
conversation verse a ssin with an yeah I
think it's too it's too ambitious right
now okay well we should do one person
what do you think Zack I mean the AI n
yeah let's do a I n okay I wanted to
build a robots in the likeness of man so
we can always cut day I ant because he
doesn't like when when you can't tell
that it's not him talking we could it
just cost like fifty thousand dollars
fifty thousand or even a hundred so what
waiting they did sure we can do a
hundred robots make a [ __ ] doll of one
of your employees and then have sex with
it that is so [ __ ] up oh my god that's
got to be sexual yeah but that's
actually like would you rather Harvey
Weinstein make a sex doll of you alright
we remove that whole need fire Ian hire
the dolls no it's not effect I mean if
it just needs to look like you know what
I don't need to be able to [ __ ] it yeah
and anyway I don't need much to be able
to [ __ ] it like I just put a role father
yeah yeah you know put a roll of toilet
paper put some I don't know
petroleum jelly in there call it a day I
don't know I'm improvising on the cheap
budget here damn we don't budget for
this Ethan is gonna have to let you go
that's a funny idea maybe funny idea for
a sketch you like trick your employee
and to get molds of their face because
because it's entertainment right and you
say oh we're doing this thing and then
it turns out it's a full-scale [ __ ]
robot
super super disturbing and then like at
the end of the day you're like well okay
I'm gonna I'm going home and you take
your taking the robot with you it's like
why are you taking the [ __ ] robot home
with you maintenance yeah just doing
some maintenance on it that it turned up
it comes out you're having an intimate
relationship
Wow at when VR sex becomes a thing
without fall under me - or is that
that's what I was gonna ask me I me I I
mean me I hmm got me thinking you look
asking tough questions if I have sex
with an employee and VR is that sexual
harassment yes are you sure because I
can masturbate of to I can think about
an employee and masturbate to the
thought of them so what's the difference
between that and VR if you tell them it
yeah either way if you thought if you
just go home and you're like I won't
have sex with this employee in VR but
how do you do it like what's in the
privacy of your home you know but what's
the software that would allow that it's
like a deep fake thing I'm just thinking
future wise I guess that's fine if it's
like a deep fake kind of thing so so but
to get the deep fake you have to take
and discrete photos of them that's where
I'm going
that's why I was asking that's that
would be fun yeah that's really [ __ ]
up hmm these are the kinds of I like
these are the questions this coronavirus
highlight is gonna be [ __ ] lit by the
way oh you broke will cut around this
let's start over
that's right I thought okay let's get
back to the coronavirus go ahead and hit
me with that sting again for the
highlight
what about me I can see me is it on me
what's happened
yeah come on you guys there's a sound
stop it
start it over what happened to the sound
what come on off the rails it keeps
getting muted for some reason why did
you I'm not doing anything okay here we
go
[Music]
there you go
that's our little I'm gonna be talking
about the coronavirus a lot so I figured
we'd make a sting for it so the
coronavirus I have been putting together
I've been following this very closely
all the development since last we spoke
on it now I personally think from what
I've seen again
obviously I'm not a scientist but I
follow of scientists on Twitter does
that qualify me nope I personally think
that this is a huge problem I think this
can run out of control and I think that
I wish that people were taking it more
seriously like the World Health
Organization is not declaring an
emergency I feel like even hearing in
the United States people are not
preparing for the amount of illnesses
that could be coming up but anyway that
listen that's just my conspiracy theory
this is Alex Jones and you are watching
Infowars
but I actually just have media I want to
show you guys so going back a few days
is when I started taking the footage
here is pictures Chinese authorities are
cutting off roads to prevent people from
traveling outside of wool on as you guys
know these there's 50 million people
quarantined at this point and
China and they're just piling 15 or 50
55 zero mil uses yeah crazy and they're
just you cannot get out every single
road is covered over you know only in
China could you do something this insane
but it's actually a great thing it's so
good
I am deeply concerned for the people of
Wuhan though there's a there's 11
million people just in that city alone
and as you'll see I was having that
exact discussion with somebody this past
weekend about how it's like good and bad
this is happening in China not obviously
it's not good that it's happening but if
there's any country that will like pull
out all the stops oh yeah they don't
give a [ __ ] about human rights or human
decency in this one instance that maybe
is an advantage well it's seeing it does
seem the thing is what's with China it's
like it's the same thing with the USSR
these people are so protective of their
reputation and and they're so
authoritarian that's they played down
the severity of it and really on that
and and and they kind of missed the
opportunity to keep it from spreading
but they're doing their best now these
are bodies on the floor are allegedly
deceased people who remains failed to
get removed the original video was
reportedly removed by the Chinese
government so this is what the hospitals
look like and again this was posted days
ago and every day it's getting
exponentially worse some people saying
they're just sleeping so I don't it
could be either one
let's take it as a whole okay get me one
of those suits man that the doctor then
walk around the house I need them and if
I throw out virus outbreak I don't want
to be here you know I mean I wouldn't be
like alone somewhere streets are
deserted in Wuhan as people are ordered
not to leave the house there's a capital
of Wuhan 11 million people empty streets
11 million people this is like more just
New York has like 9 million this is more
than the entirety of LA County yeah City
of LA there's one of the most densely
populated cities in the whole world just
completely deserted
pretty crazy frightening yeah
the only magic this was bustling just a
week ago so there you have it when you
doing food and stuff that's part of the
concerns that they have got this
quarantine yeah all these people and
they're trying to get supplies in from
less I heard they have food and supplies
but the one thing that they don't have
they've run out of masks and you look
really beautiful you know I had to say
you're just really struck me in the
middle of this Wuhan segment thank you I
just was overcome by admiration anyway
you did you were looking at me like I
was like wow look at me I got this this
wife is incredible anyway they've got
they've running out of medical masks and
hazmat suits things that you actually
need to prevent the spread of the
infection as you'll see I have some I
have some media on that later I thought
of everything this is a little info
graph a gif highlighting the spread of
the infection look at that whoa
January 3rd 14 20 21 23 it's the same
day
no now what's what's scary - is that so
scientists thought it originated in
sometime in November at this seafood
market where they were they sell Bush me
they sell wild animals which by the way
SAR started them [ __ ] China from
these psychos eating feral meat yeah
isn't the current maybe there's been an
update but isn't the current theory that
it's a bat virus from that yeah yeah
that has it's basically from bats
you know UCP there's a video of someone
eating a bat and soup can you pull that
image up it's so gross
just find wild bats and then eat them I
mean what cut that's like and apparently
I also write that the feral musics are
more expensive than farmed meats because
it's a delicacy so they're actually
paying a premium to end humanity over
there just the Google image this is what
yeah it looks like this that's why
everybody's dying because someone wanted
to put ten wild potentially I don't
think it's a hundred percent confirmed
where but this is the kind of thing by
the way people do like you don't even
like fillet it or prepare it it's just a
boiled back what I mean man people can
look it's not my taste for damn I don't
know how you can just be small to bat
like that mmm
cream cheese I don't know sack would you
rather use cream cheese or a bat I'll
take the bat you [ __ ] you ended the
world with that so what I was saying is
originally they thought it came from
this market which would mean which mean
it started in November but actually they
figured out that seven people from the
original outbreak had never been to the
market so it's point of origin now
they're trying to figure out predates
the market and that's bad news because
one they don't have it figured out and
two it means the the virus has been
spreading for longer mmm-hmm the virus
has like a 10-day incubation period
where you're not showing symptoms but
what's dangerous about this particular
virus were for example SARS did not have
this characteristic is that it can be
contagious during the incubation period
so while there are no symptoms you can
pass the virus on that's what's so
insidious about it here's a video of
people just falling down sick and China
watch
the street that's down on the streets in
the hospital they're just collapsing no
yeah it's terrifying I'm scared for
these people man the problem is people I
see people downplaying it they go it's
just the flu well that's true but the
problem is is that nobody has resistance
nobody's body has ever seen this so the
problem is that everybody catches it and
then we are medical professionals and
abilities become so overstrained from
the volume of sick people that nobody
can get medical attention for example
people like me and HeLa would probably
be fine it's like having the flu it
sucks you get over in a week but our son
if he got sick from this that could be
life-threatening and then when you try
to go to the hospital to get him
treatment to save his life there's
thousands of people there and no one can
give him medical attention nobody can
give him medicine
nobody can treat him there's nothing
that's that's the danger set in LA with
a population of 5 million you have a
million people who are sick old people
and young people and people with immune
system deficiencies are gonna die by the
tens of thousands for those millions
yeah I mean it'll be it well right now
it's uh they're saying it's like about 2
to 3% it's estimated it's like 2 to 3
percent
fatality rate which you know that means
two or three out of a hundred people
what is huge what I read is it's it's
hard to say yet because it can take a
while to die from this so right now
they're saying whatever 40,000 people
have the virus who and then you know it
takes a couple of weeks before you
actually find out the mortality rate so
what I read is it's somewhere between
two and ten percent mortality rate
ma'am it's hard to tell but even at 2%
with a million people infected that's
20,000 deaths so if you go up to if with
the population united states you've got
300 million people if a third gets sick
which would probably be even more if it
was a pandemic then 2 percent of 100
million is 20 million people
that's a big deal it's not good that's
more than every war we've ever fought
combined I think the Chinese are
actually is there audio playing back
there I hear something or is it our
neighbor it might be the neighbor I
don't hear anything so weird that China
I just clicked this one sorry
the Chinese are actually their
industrial capabilities are so
incredible they are building a thousand
bed hospital in six days
look at this it's just a field of
hundreds of cranes just digging look at
the I mean that's unbelievable that
Chinese industrial capabilities so
they're building one mega hospital and
they're already building another one
that's even bigger that should be done
in a week it's unbelievable that shot is
crazy I know a movie or something yeah I
mean it looks like ants they look just
looking bugs it's like a hundred mega
machines just look at all the materials
it seriously reminds me of like a
disaster movie when they're enacting the
plan to save everybody totally I'm
moving yeah that's crazy yeah so that's
what's going on in there right now to
try to provide more beds but I'm afraid
it's not even gonna be close to enough
people working in China I don't know
what that means that's here
oh here's people in their office look
oh thank you yeah this is what people in
their office are doing you see this you
know they have their own station
covering Plateau my god so they're
working at their computer and their
whole station they're in like their own
bubbles of plastic wrap probably yeah
I saw a thing this morning that uh what
do you like surgical masks are selling
out like crazy here in the States
yeah you can't buy him anymore at like
well Walgreens really they're they're
trying to tell people it literally does
nothing I would not do anything to
prevent you from you that's not true
that's not what I heard
if you use it correctly it can really
help is what I heard no not the surgical
mask things not the surgical masks you
need like a infectious man yeah like a
respirator yeah something like that
not a respirator but I'm saying the
surgical masks are the things that
people are rushing out to buy and that
that literally you might as well just
not wear so there's one that's like
waterproof on the outside and absorbent
on the inside those are the ones you
want for infectious diseases well those
are probably flying off the shelf so
here someone this guy found the cure
yeah he's smoking a cigarette with the
mask but this I was watching a video of
a Chinese doctor explaining this is the
one you want it's blue on the outside
which is waterproof lining and on the
inside there's some kind of absorbent
material the cigarette I'm not sure on
how that affects the viability of the
mask but god bless him so here this is
when it gets really scary you start to
see oh no somebody removed it oh man I
can't believe the Chinese government is
actually removing these videos from
YouTube oh let me try to find a reflow
real fast this video was incredible I
have to find it
which one was that's I was like no way
that China's gonna start removing this
bro and [ __ ] China's removing this
that's so scary that they can do that I
think I found it it's got all these
watermarks and shit's so corny
there's like WorldStarHipHop com
Malaysia like the one I had didn't have
any watermark so how did these guys are
douches like imagining your watermarks
are well I imagine putting your
watermark on my video like this did you
hear that allegedly TMZ broke then Kobe
Bryant knows news even to the family I'm
not surprised those guys I don't know
what's up with them but they I don't
know how they always do that but I did I
know they broke the story I was gonna be
here I was talking to ABC News I was
listening to ABC News and they go it was
reported today by TMZ that Kobe Bryant
died in a plane crash like they're even
giving them credit I know I think you're
like if you just heard it happen and I
got at least make sure the family knows
as if you're at Ian's that's classic
media shenanigans you know what I mean
they want to be the first to break the
story and they don't care about anything
so she's speaking Mandarin so I'm gonna
have to read the subtitles so you guys
you know can you turn it up a little bit
real quick I should I was curious
because I got removed if it might have
been because people were saying it's
fake
and there is some dispute as to the
validity of this video so we should
probably say that might have been why it
got taken off YouTube why would it why
wouldn't you - apparently the this is a
BBC article about it and says the woman
who does not identify herself is wearing
protective suit in an unknown location
however her suit and mask do not match
the ones worn by any medical staff in
the province of hoobie who by well you
know there's such a shortage I don't I
don't know that that qualifies I mean
you've got 11 million people there
you've got no medical stuff I feel like
that are you I don't think that is
enough to discredit it but you guys
judge for yourself here sure
obviously in China you can't speak out
against the government so the
that she's not identifying herself and
in Anna yes location sure like for them
to cite that as somehow disputing the
videos it's just stupid it's insulting
but regardless here's the video you guys
judge for yourself dear friends my name
is Jin here she just identified herself
I think it was a fake name maybe I don't
know because in the original one the
subtitle said something like the name
was like censored up I don't know anyway
dear friends my name is Jin Hume I'm
currently at the infected encode
district in Wuhan let me brief you on
the current situation of Hubei Province
in China so far more than 90,000 people
by the way this is several days ago so
it's much worse now have been affected
by the corona virus what is the
infection rate not media quarantine or
effective treatment one infected person
can pass the virus to 14 or more nearby
the infection rate is extremely high
that was the Chinese New Year holiday
season family members friends sons and
daughters are all on their way rushing
home for a family reunion for a family
dinner together
however this is a grave moment I urge
you not to go out do not attend any
party do not visit anyone there's always
another Chinese New Year as long as you
stay safe and well we have many
opportunities to catch up so this was
actually the Chinese government issued
statements similar to what she just said
which was they urging everyone to stay
at home and not go out by the way the
timing of this virus couldn't be worse
with the Chinese New Year make people
traveling they're traveling within China
you know in China they they take off
work a whole month during the New Year's
to celebrate so everyone's on vacation
they're traveling around all around the
world I mean the timing truly could not
be worse for this thing I don't see why
someone would fake that I mean they
didn't even it all seems pretty
congruent with the fact except she says
it has a 17 person infection rate so
that's not exactly what mom who knows
but here I mean I have one that's even
more frightening this guy by the way is
someone I've been following closely dr.
Eric dink
he's a harvard-educated doctor I
actually I'm gonna look like an idiot
but he's an epidemiologist which is
someone who studies viruses right
epidemics epidemiologists correct he's a
PhD at Harvard and this guy has been
freaking out about this virus document
how the World Health Organization used
to be calling it an emergency now he
says holy mother of God the new corona
virus is a 3.8 that's the infectious
scale that means one person infects 3.8
other people it is thermonuclear
pandemic level bad never seen an actual
virility coefficient outside of Twitter
and my entire career I'm not
exaggerating we estimate the basic
reproduction number of the infection to
be 3.8 indicating that 72 to 75% of
transmissions must be prevented by
control measures trying to find one that
actually it makes sense and isn't
science lingo that what makes sense he's
saying that if in order to stop the
trend of more more people getting it
they need to be able to stop about 75%
of the transmissions like you need to
cut down transmissions by three-quarters
of what's currently happening for it to
slow down at all says travel
restrictions from and to Wuhan City
are unlikely to be effective in halting
transmission against China with a 99%
effective reduction travel the size of
the epidemic outside Wuhan may only be
reduced by twenty four point nine
percent our findings are critically
dependent on the assumption underpinning
our model and the timing and reporting
of confirmed cases there's considerable
uncertainty associated with the outbreak
at the early stages someone asked them
do you think China is reporting actual
numbers or do you think they're
suppressing information he said by all
reports I highly doubt the cases and
deaths counts are accurate authorities
already admit the numbers are too low
but knowing Chinese media it's always
worse than they admit I predict numbers
will soar in the next two five figures
he said over the weekend and six figures
within the next two weeks worldwide ooh
this guy has been freaking me out
dr. Aric ding he's my guy I've been
going to for updates let's see what he's
been if he's tweeting anything recently
he's so what he's been saying is that
it's way worse than SARS it's contagious
before symptoms appear making it hard to
isolate and quarantine in the sense of
it spreads much more easily than SARS
right well if you know because you you
don't know you're sick so you cannot
quarantine the virus you don't know
you're for two weeks yeah
well it's in LA now so good luck though
yeah it's in USC which is [ __ ] really
close in Orange County which is really
close I'm trying to let see because so
far everywhere outside of China where
they have a few people got it they seem
to be in a stable position they're not
dying but they're if they're passed
that's the that's not the problem isn't
if they're dying the problem is it if
they're passing it and you don't know if
they passed it for a week and then a lot
of people were speculating
well so far you know we haven't seen
everyone who's got it overseas in Japan
and Germany and the United States
whatever they're all people that were
went to Wuhan China came back from Milan
China but it just broke just today five
hours ago that someone who was sick in
Germany and someone who's in sick in
Japan never went to Wuhan which means
that the virus was transmitted they were
in contact and some with someone who was
yes Edward themselves but they were so
people were waiting to see if the virus
was going to make a jump to people who
hadn't directly visited Wuhan and so
that confirmed the fear the hope people
had that it wouldn't transmit like that
building and China saying to stay at
home here's up here check this out the
government these buildings are lit up
with public service announcement saying
promise me stay at home during Chinese
New Year's is that okay be a healthy
little fatty it says go to the hospital
if you have any symptoms ASAP so the
building's all have like these red alert
PSA warnings a little fatty yeah I like
that that's funny that's a it's a team
term of endearment
this one was a bit contested because its
market this guy says there's gunshots
but people are setting off firecrackers
I guess because it's the new year
he was saying that people were trying to
escape the quarantine and there was
gunfire I don't I think it's
firecrackers but you could just see
people on the ground
now is not the time for firecrackers
they sound like firecrackers but yeah
that seems like a weird here's the time
to be here's the police in China are
throwing suspected infected people in a
quarantine van watch this [ __ ]
you can hear the firecrackers in this
club but watch this is horrifying
he didn't want to get in the van in the
police so forced him in the choking him
out and they're forcing him in it was a
new kind of like never seen him before
disaster going on 20 20 do a scary [ __ ]
body police throwing infected people in
a van more photo of people trying to
escape Wuhan here's someone trying to
get out some other way blocked off there
was a story by the way some Chinese
traveler she was on social media
bragging about how she came from Wuhan
she had a trip to Paris plan she was
bragging about how she went around the
quarantine and made it to Paris and then
people on social media reported to
police and she got deported but that
just goes to show you know it just takes
a couple of people like that says this
photo was sent to me a few hours ago by
someone I know who won they haven't yet
got the virus and they tried to leave
the city to take their family to safety
every road out was blocked
[Music]
here so this one this one really scared
me this is a leaked voice message you
can see came through on whatsapp I will
read the subtitles for you as well but
it's from a whatsapp chat here or
something like it I've been working all
day long now I am off duty
I took off around 4:00 p.m. I haven't
crying my eyes out
indeed the affection is much more
horrible than what's reported on TV
there are so many cases doctors have
estimated about a hundred thousand and
fifty and we have more than ten doctors
here and each doctor has treated more
than ten a hundred infected people in
just one day many of them will not make
it no hospital bed
the relatives complained and insist on
being treated in our hospital and they
quoted the government's promise and the
hospital should treat those infected
with the preneur voice however the
government didn't support us with
medical supplies we don't have enough
resources to hospitalized patients it
won't work if the situation's worsens
like this we have been slammed all day
long we are called breaking down we
cannot take it anymore
the patients were begging us desperately
but we couldn't do anything you're dying
right in front of our eyes
therefore please take every measure to
protect yourself at home don't ever
trust the government we are on our own
now
that seems I mean I don't know that
seems real to me do like
someone said the translations have been
confirmed by Chinese speakers mono
thought but yeah
so that does [ __ ] I don't know ma'am
here is footage in Wuhan of people just
public officials just spraying
disinfectants on the street good [ __ ]
government health employees are spraying
chemical disinfectant on the streets of
Chinese cities under quarantine an
effect in an effort to combat the deadly
virus does that work fill my room up
with that [ __ ] yeah you want to walk in
a bubble though with that [ __ ] so
according to dr. Eric dink the guy I was
telling you about he was saying how long
ago did the corona virus emerge and
start spreading the atom virus from all
others are descended first appeared no
earlier than October 30th and no later
than November 29th which means 1.5 to
2.5 months of unconfined proliferation
oh this the corona virus arrives in
Orange County I'm reading like the
bullet points from the what's that
infection game role play game yeah I'm
giving like plague update coronavirus
arrives in Orange County yeah oh here's
a good one the government was planning a
quarantine zone in Hong Kong and the
protesters burned it down set it fire
check it out group of protesters set
fire to plant quarantine building in
Hong Kong I thought there was a video
well they were saying apparently that
they had some reason they thought it was
some stupid thing that like it didn't
make sense where they put it earlier
afternoon 100 of regular Hong Kong
citizens had blocked roads leading to
buildings with bricks and other debris
as anger cruise towards government plant
to convert the building into a
quarantine zone as the number of
confirmed cases in the city climbed to 6
on Sunday 50,000 residents within 500
meters how can a quarantine can't be
built here
oh I guess they were saying it's too
densely populated here for a quarantine
building say how can a quarantine camp
bill built here [ __ ] government they
wrote this on the I guess PC culture
hasn't reached China yet don't they know
you can't say [ __ ] we have to cancel
China well what can we do
hold on I got more eula what can we do
about it Oh coronavirus arrived in
Israel that shocked me here's this
footage from a hospital in Israel this
actually is really interesting footage
they look how they've got it all locked
up they taking her out of the back of a
ambulance and uh like crazy quarantine
box they're not [ __ ] around you see
that's he so just imagine in China
there's a hundred thousand people
walking around and and then but this is
how dangerous it is what I know I was
impressed a lick hockey I did these guys
have too many threats everywhere to deal
with the corona and World Wars World War
Z Israel was the only country that
survived that's right that's awesome I'm
proud of that what was the explanation
for that
well it's fiction first of all don't
stop it yeah that's real don't take this
away from me what how did they survive
because they built a wall because there
you had the one exactly right and they
they like immediately closed off the
entire country oh that's good for them
you see it works
they're like secretly being like the
walls dump you guys well again real
fictional zombie there was a case caught
here we go everybody get ready
Oh people are going to masks factories
in China and begging outside the gate
for mass because they're sold out you
can't get them going directly to the
factory look at it like a concentration
camp is begging for mass
a [ __ ] crazy
this one is pretty strange to me this
work what I don't know what is the mouse
gonna do so much that it's worth like
begging here like that well actually
there's a really good video I'll show
you of a doctor explaining it cuz
apparently there's some
misunderstandings about it
Chinese doctor explains mask it was
really good it was uh where was I was
seeing it all over Twitter can you guys
sure mmm I wish I saved it no but he it
is very effective he says if you as long
as you cover your nose all the way down
who's showing how to proper use it if
you have the right one it can like 90%
help reduce your exposure to the virus
okay so it is very effective because I
always thought it's more to protect from
you infecting people you put the mask on
I guess it depends on the type of mask
but I think that's probably just because
you've never been in it like when you go
to like Urgent Care they give you a mask
no way if you're a sick yeah but we've
never been in the situation where we had
a pandemic to deal with but he was
saying these are very effective outsides
waterproof inside has padding it's very
good it's got to cover your whole mouth
and nose like from here to here so I
thought that was interesting video which
had it for you did she see but anyway
there was this case confirmed in Germany
a case confirmed in San Diego a case
confirmed at USC campus they sent an
email to the students last night at 3
a.m. I was up cleaning that was right
before Alfredo puked [ __ ] and this just
happened last night you can see it went
out oh it says 10:40 p.m. so they say
attention residents the health of our
community is a top priority for us
tonight a resident was transported to a
local hospital for treatment and
diagnosed with the corona virus out of
China there's currently no reason to
believe the virus has spread beyond this
isolated incident however we take this
very seriously and
keep the community posted as new
information becomes available
USC not far what do you want to do
anything I don't know I just think that
though I think that the government and
the World Health Organization need to
start taking this more seriously like
nobody's acts everybody like is just
acting like it's all good I don't know I
don't see people really worried about
this I like in government I don't see ID
on the news I don't see the president I
don't see officials talk to you and the
World Health Organization has not yet
declared an emergency I don't understand
how that's possible
huh they keep saying like the World
Health Organization they say the rate
the risk to you they say in China it's
very high in the region it's medium and
outside of the region it's low so
they're saying it's not an emergency but
I just don't I don't understand taking
all the information into account I know
that there are scientists and
professionals and I hope I'm wrong but
it seems to me that I don't know
I don't know I mean what can we do
nothing there's nothing we can do except
just hope that I'm wrong and if I'm not
wrong I'd like to see the more
preparation for this yeah people are not
taking it seriously also in America I
don't think that they're not taking it
seriously it just seems like if you're
over there yes I don't see them on TV
talking about it seems like here it's
different I don't see any preparation
happening but also it there needs to be
some public discourse because in China
if you get a fever you're gonna know oh
I probably have this thing I need to go
see a doctor but in America or outside
the region people who are getting sick
is flu season after all are not gonna
think about it and they're not gonna
consider this possibility so it's gonna
make the situation even worse mm-hmm
without some kind of public education I
hope I'm wrong because everyone was
saying you know SARS came and went and
nobody and it wasn't a big deal and
nothing happened but from what I
understand this is more dangerous than
SARS and I hope I'm wrong and I look
like an idiot for like panicking about
this and making a whole hub up about it
but I do find it very concerning and I'm
not I don't know you know I don't like
it I don't like it I like it I don't
like it I like it
soundbite that say I like it I don't
like it perfect we'll get that I like it
I like I like it I like it I like it I
like it
you said it's been two hours down yeah
just about its I'm waiting to see how
it's gonna affect all the businesses who
do business with China because
everything is made in China
I'm afraid China is going to be so
[ __ ] by this yeah they're gonna be so
[ __ ] by this because well China it's
so populist and it's so densely
populated it's a perfect place for virus
like this to spread and they eat and
it's where they all start because these
crazy people are eating bats now China
has the resources and they have wealth
to deal with it on to a degree if this
virus hits a place like India they will
be destroyed by it because they have a
huge population they have dense
population but they do not have the
resources to combat this there's a ton
of poverty there people [ __ ] on the
street there you know what I mean no it
is going on it will destroy it will be
so dangerous in a country like India
that's like the worst case scenario I
feel like we'll see well no well no you
know in the coming days how bad this
thing's gonna be I hope I'm wrong start
praying
you can pray you can know that I'll be
following it though you want your Corona
my Corona updates you know where to find
them
dr. Moses they follow dr. Dean you
dingus you ding-dong
well there's so much more I wanted to
talk about but I guess we have for life
outside the podcast don't we you have to
work I've to go get the baby dude
in our babysitter living on three no not
today
oh thank god I just panicked thirty five
my Corona
so that rap that concludes our report on
the corona virus go ahead Ian with the
my Corona crack open a fresh one well I
wanted to talk about Jase station I
wanted to talk about ninja mixer deal do
tells I wanted to talk about so many
other things left to save them for later
Jane qualified eight percent nationally
he's already on the next stage and of
course Dan is hating like a coward on
yank friends our yeah well cowardly
about what's cowardly about it is that
you don't have the strength or resolve
to even understand what you're talking
about it it's cowardly it's yellow okay
we're going to talk about that on Friday
though Friday we have a guest as I write
them we do the the great Gus Johnson
will be joining us Eddie will also be
joining us Oh Willie yes how exciting
cool so Gus and Eddie that's it Gus and
Eddie podcast go seddie seddie seddie
years oh they michael avenatti trial has
started really does anyone else excited
any news just that it started he's in it
started he's in federal prison now i
said you want to say can you still
believe that he tried to bribe nike
twenty million dollars awesome nike
immediately went to that yeah guys like
hire you [ __ ] dumb i feel
unbelievably vindicated by all of this
because when he first likes sure the
senior now you are early adopter i was
just like this guy scum like just yeah
saw right through it and
turns out I was right my parent my
family got taken with him they thought
he was the [ __ ] tell me yeah he needs to
run for president we need somebody like
shows like that how on so there they are
the same has Trump supporters that they
so despise if you are ready to vote from
avenatti you are Trump supporter you
know you are what you despise I must you
know how American go okay well so Friday
we can we'll talk about these things
with the Dustin Eddie yeah the J station
stuff for sure I'm sure they're up to
date on all that so how was my coverage
of corona Thoreau uh it's kind of dark
very dark and I like it I like it yeah I
mean I don't like it I like it I don't
like it I like I don't like it well
let's wrap it up then we'll be back on
Friday guys I want to go spend some time
with Theodore my son my one and only son
eight months old and just about one week
Wow
Theodore my one and only son I can't
wait to talk to him I can't wait for him
to start talking you got any updates he
starts going dad dad dad dad dad I think
he's saying that he loves his dad dad or
like you know in Hebrew you say die like
stop no he's not saying die he hasn't
heard us saying die enough he's saying
dad why does he love his dad so much I
feel like I don't deserve it
well he's always reaching out for me and
happy to see me and it's just crazy
well you you it's just it's crazy that
it's just it's really cool when he will
see us it's like ah he's stoked yeah
my throat is it Jim
what your [ __ ] mic dude it's funny
I'm scratching my throat you never done
that no that's done that right Zach
honestly I've never done yeah wow you
sound like a pig in mud with boys uh-huh
I know of other people that do that I
guess it's like an allergy thing where
your throat it's itchy inside here so I
don't know why that bothers me
are his headphones off dance such a
[ __ ] a seder you should have saw this
conversation we had about gang last
night he was pissing me off he's talking
[ __ ] on Yang and I was like bro you mean
no I wasn't talking [ __ ] I'm realistic
about his electoral you know you were
saying that anyone who supports the end
is basically a Nazi let's wrap it up
you'll be here on Friday I had a great
time here today and I had a great time
here today what can I say what else can
I say it was a good time yeah we had a
great time lots of tragedies yeah
actually I don't give that chicken 12:00
Fredo
because I had diarrhea Annie as I read I
wonder if it's that chicken
maybe I'll boil it I don't even know I
was talking about tragedy yeah no we're
wrapping it up I'm just talking about
I've moved on
I'm not in the podcast it okay I'm
always the show yeah the show's over do
you want to fall not yes sure
bye everybody see you on Friday with
God's amazing Saturday
[Music]